what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to start up
Star Wars Visions we're gonna do this
three episodes per video Michael you
good we gotta get to it buddy we got a
lot of Visions to watch be good I'm good
so good good they gotta leave a like use
the force leave a like that would mean a
lot also by the way full interaction
watching alongs where you sing with your
own copy of Visions available for super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page thank
you to all who have joined us over there
so far so many of you have joined all of
our Star Wars Visions reactions we got a
sponsor who I love working with get out
of the video for a little bit Michael
thank you again to meonies for
sponsoring this video guys I'm in a
onesie I've never owned a onesie and my
epidermis has never felt more
comfortable nay I need a better word
than comfortable I feel
has snug as a bug in a rug I obviously
love their clothing I went to the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere
and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants and people would not stop
talking about it easily the most
comfortable one there at the event now
I'm venturing further into the galaxy
far far away you might say with this
limited edition print of grogu AKA baby
Yoda cause the child himself grogu has
traveled across the Galaxy and into our
hearts and now you can meditate with him
and galactically soft undies socks
bralettes loungewear and more available
in sizes extra small to 4XL like I said
the new Star Wars Prince is limited so
grab this bounty now before it's all
gone they also gave me their shorts
which again is so soft and perfect
fitting too even my wife loves to wear
them speaking of my wife I even got this
bralette for her too I said take it off
I'm showing it in the video a woman she
loves seeing me in this underwear my
Jedi Mind Tricks to keep her attracted
to me don't work but this underwear is
doing the job wearing it right now I've
never been more relaxed on camera
sitting has just generally never felt so
soothing but yes rejection the hype is
real you're not impressed with me undies
your first pair is on the house Seth is
a promise so to get 25 off your first
order and free standard shipping go to
mianis.com rejects once again that is
miyanis.com Rejects and May the force be
with you always I hope they partner up
with us again because
yes
[Music]
I'd like to hear it
oh
very interesting
oh we're after a good start
this is gorgeous
Gorge awesome I did not know a Droid POV
is what I needed
this looks like the show arcane
Wally
I love the look of this I would watch a
show of this
will inspire me to finish the painting
let's see through paints
[Music]
wow this feels so cyber punky
love it
Star Wars into the star version
just a really neat concept to explore a
force using artists
wow look at that oh the dimension shift
it's like an iMac shift
wow
it's just like the use of transparency
there's a video game where you just like
paint like this
that's pretty cool
what that game's called but it looks
like this
oh interesting there's the Sith
I love their use of just like loose
sketches
I expect the first episode to have such
mind-blowing animation yeah
oh hello there
oh it's like the Sith is dripping
I hate when that happens
oh she like sensing the Sith
maybe this is how she expresses her
dark side Beacon seven always failing
this is about to be you absolutely
gorgeous I can feel it
the rebels are left
you're so cool
oh man
it reminds me a bit of Grievous ship
great shot
I'm actually sure they have like that
identical shot in the Ahsoka trailer but
of Sabine
[Music]
oh the platformings look like an eye is
watching her this doesn't look
stay here
I love this Droid someone destroyed this
I literally I right yeah yeah that's
exactly what they're going for oh
I love this guy
those are some cool tendrils
paint over him uh-oh
you
you I know safe anymore
Ah
that's a nice change of pace
yeah
I love this electronic score
oh baby
it's like a nebula Winter Soldier yeah
okay
holy I just got goosebumps
everywhere
this is so cool
oh man she just wants to paint Tred
better be okay
oh boy
oh don't you dare vision
that was great
right the Dome
no oh
didn't even the news
Star Wars
the paint might actually be part of this
oh wow pain over him
floors some stuff they're so dramatic
Ray Skywalker that's like a cool Tonto
oh my God oh my God this is beautiful
wow
[Music]
found my own path
you're in her world now the Light Side
Darkness
this is so freaking beautiful
let's talk about visual language
and darkness
yes balance
oh it's great
brilliant
I love this guys I'm not even joking I'm
literally editing this right now and I I
just had chills the entire time just
editing this episode that's so good
oh damn that's like some Thanos level of
beliefs right here gets killed is like
yes you did good daughter you have a
thick skin buddy no
I love this ship
gorgeous
nice great painting balance he was right
about one thing
I am the master now and I can paint I
am the master now
paint your own destiny gorgeous I loved
it two out of ten Greg clearly not
enough lizzo we gotta keep these short
because we got ourselves a few more to
get through my God I was like a
combination of the animation from like
Arcane Spider-Man into the spider-verse
whatever I saw in the trailer for puss
and moves I haven't actually seen Puss
in Boots lately mixed with a bit of that
like ethereal tone of like a Leica film
you know those types of properties like
ParaNorman another one I haven't uh well
no I've seen paranormal ParaNorman and
they're like Coraline and stuff like
that like those kind of movies as well I
love how this was about a person who
just painting as her New Path they kept
that as a consistent aesthetic
throughout the entire experience and its
expression I thought it was beautiful I
would have watched an entire like 80 to
90 minute movie if this was the case I
fell in love with that instantly I
completely agree uh I I think striking
that creative balance was just so
refreshing and I think it's my favorite
part of Visions is expressing the force
through these kind of visual means
allows you to just do so much more than
you know what the traditional films and
and TV shows are able to do so yeah cool
we got a Latino actress in there to do
it yeah awesome that was badass yeah
yeah I I completely agree and it's it's
one of those like de facto
representation is my favorite
representation where it's not even like
it's just it's not even a thing yeah I
didn't even think about it until you
said that which is awesome I saw the
director was like Rodrigo or something
or another I don't know what else he's
done but yeah that was awesome what did
you guys think about it leave it down
below I guess my one worry is like did
you start off so high that it can't
match that high yeah it was just the
trick to get us to watch another one was
this the peak of Nine episodes we'll see
how it goes but I thought that was
mesmerizing absolutely mesmerizing
screen choose reach ah
space orphans am I right yeah
pick you up this is really cool I like
the 2D effect I feel like I'm uh playing
The Fallout Shelter mobile game
it literally looks like a Pip Boy it's
like an arcade level of like the old
school games Donkey Kong up on the top
[Music]
I would play this game
I'm going to screeches reach no way that
place is haunting we
steal some speeders
uh what's going on oh my God you want to
see a ghost
did they say his name is Cal
M this is really really pretty
it's so nice to see 2D animation just
just doing its thing
hand-drawned or something to it I mean
obviously a little bit digital touch-up
but
at least the Android effect yeah the
ghost
creatures reach
well we're gonna be the first oh face
the sound of that screaming no they're
just stories right now
tell the ghost isn't a thing you can
touch you see it in your mind plus Cal's
not Irish I'm
the redheads beats the workhouse
what if you didn't have to go back to
the workhouse or a girl there are worse
lives now
There Are Better Lives
where you could use the horse that got
out of here
yeah
oh this is cute you've always wanted
something more on it what that is take
it don't look back
you're gonna travel in style better hold
on that's all expressed we're going on
an adventure
it's a little bit dark in here we'll
stop we'll stop
I follow your path with strength and
courage
a good little catholic
[Music]
loving this music
doll we need to stick together
oh my gosh Dow I've heard a different
name every time he said their name
's in here haunting I don't want to see
a ghost
I saw the ghosts
holy wow
there's like some J horror crap I'm here
for it
oh wow
she's in pain
what's your motive here
don't worry
why are you trying to defeat this thing
that was unexpected
it's like a soul has become so corrupt
oh
[Music]
wow that is terrifying
go towards the light
oh that was an amazing shot oh
creepy demonic and fast that thing was
but it still needed a lightsaber to get
the job
struck me down in anger
[Music]
but I'll become more powerful than you
could possibly imagine
oh wow Sal's first kill I murdered a
crazy nothing helps me find the
Light Side better than murder
and permanently scared you gave me
strength
it's time for time to meet
Guided by a Sith
that was a nice plot twist
oh that's cool
we'll strike down your friends now
damn the way that boat ship moves down
the foreground moves with it
hello there the true test is always in
your mind and you did what you had to do
right this looks like the Yellow
Submarine cartoon
come child
are my friends too
no
it's only you
don't look back
right
[Music]
oh so misguided
fascinating it's like a cautionary tale
of Temptation that is awful
this is dark and beautiful
that left me very hungry for more it
happens man take it away Michael I
kicked off the first one you kick off
this one
I loved that I was not expecting that uh
watching Star Wars is really hard these
days uh no I mean it it was uh beautiful
I also just like from a
Star Wars perspective there's something
really fun about like exploring someone
getting recruited to the dark side who
is
literally just trying to like Escape
their means I loved the animation style
it captured a child like in a sense that
I think made the story all the more like
oh that's just so unsettling uh and also
the ghost was terrifying uh I think
straight up was like don't poop your
pants on the real rejects uh
and I didn't want to be the first time
someone's done it I believe that uh
I believe that not naming any names yeah
what did you think Greg uh yeah I
thought it was great I mean it's it's
yeah it's definitely like an adjustment
to go from the first one to this one
because they're such different Vibes and
I kind of like prepared ourselves for
yeah all right you know they usually
start off strong let's see how it goes
but I thought this was great yeah I mean
the latter half of it was the most
enticing part when it actually became
something that felt horrific everything
with the ghost that I thought was cool
it's like when the ghost said the
lightsaber was like we really need to go
with the lightsaber at this point I had
that thing tick off in my brain but for
ultimately what it turned into
um because I like how they use they have
to tell these stories at a very they
rely so much on tone and mood and the
atmosphere they have to have this like
very strong laconic way of expressing
themselves I think they did just that so
they didn't have the reveal come around
like you talked about the innocence and
how this Sith preys on innocence
presents themselves as it's like a
savior into a new beautiful kind of
world like look at me doubt and white in
the light but you know it's a Sith I
think is great because this kid has no
idea like you're actually going on a
really dark path right now yeah yeah but
they don't know so I think that's
compared to being stuck true that's true
yeah that's
uh no I I completely agree as a
Storyteller I have so much respect for
this kind of short form storytelling
because in an age where we rely so much
upon like lore and an exposition and all
you know what's become an essential part
of the viewing experience it is really
really refreshing to in the familiar
broad setting of a story like Star Wars
be able to just give storytellers a like
unconsequential to Canon opportunity to
explore a deeper more meaningful art
form and honestly like for all the
things that people say about Lucas film
huge Kudos because green lighting a
project like this and giving it two
seasons is a pretty extraordinary move
you know especially when you consider
every one of these companies is like a
legendary Animation Studio in their own
right and yeah
um for them to take their time teams and
talent and like find me a single
Storyteller artist that wasn't inspired
by Star Wars like you can only imagine
in a creative process for each of these
there's this like overwhelming feeling
of like wow this might be my one chance
to get to leave my mark on this galaxy
sure and like they don't disappoint true
true let's watch the third one and get
disappointed Greg yeah you know great
points but we got seven of these more to
go through
so comfortable in this
okay
Punk Robot in the Stars
it all takes place and it doesn't have
this better be a musical oh I'm really
curious what the rest of the style is
gonna be up that playmation
that's gorgeous
wow
they are spoiling us
magic mushrooms
this kind of reminds me a little bit of
uh Andor and the star sequence they had
kind of
wow there's a real uncanny effect here
this is cool
that Searchlight yeah I was gonna say
TIE fighter with a spotlight
oh
are you pretending to be a Jedi
I love how you can feel the scale
these sets are so pretty
that's the rock where aslen was
resurrected you are wasting it no this
is important it's from Anna Stone
I've really been enjoying the voiceover
work too yeah right
[Music]
oh wow do you still remember Sister oh I
feel like six mom had a great strength
she always said that we had it too Lilo
and Stitch we were happy then
God this is beautiful they came
so cool it's like the historical cave
paintings yeah I love it calligraphy
this is exposition done right for the
record
oh
[Music]
Man became a star
oh all right
everybody looking down on us from the
sky
converted back to New energy be one with
the Stars we're not alone
we are
what a cool wall have your history just
etched onto there drink my
Mission this would have been beautiful
to see on the big screen we don't have
more clean water
that would have been nice for them to do
like the old days when they'd show short
animated films or yeah great use of
these
[Music]
that's exactly what godmother deals
literally Lilo and Stitch
yeah this is so beautiful just takes
that long to get there huh
what are they producing here it looks
like a water treatment facility which
seems stupid because they could have
just not poisonous
God all this work to barely get any
water
ah
same thing I mean whenever I babysit
I like these uniforms yeah
stop right there
oh
now this is a Star Wars level
oh this music
[Music]
back down doing useful stuff
I'll rent you
should you still have the water yeah I
hope so
I love these it's like the animation is
such a character in these oh I
completely agree
the textures of their costumes I thought
there were none of them left
oh it's nice to see a woman Imperial
officer for once
I want to know we won
one
does that reach your quota yeah
after that's broke
this little girl man
you're gonna get your older sister
killed
[Music]
you're going to get your older sister
killed man
pick up the broomstick
pick up the broomstick what do you think
you are doing
man this planet resources belong to
Queen Elizabeth sorry
it seems like a really
uneffective or unnecessary
[Music]
I swear if she dies
she has the force her sister's gonna
have the force
[Music]
come on there it is
again very unnecessary
crush it
together come on
together do what your sister was trying
to do
foreign
that is touching wow this is really
moving Ohana means family
wow
this is gorgeous
these are in clean water now
the alkaline purifies it
all the medicalorians
skies are clear their mom starts gonna
be so proud of them they are all here
[Music]
and this season's on another level Jesus
Christ
[Music]
are they all look at this consistent wow
oh my god oh it chills again man
oh gosh
mom
we will never be alone
boy that was beautiful oh man God I hate
this show that's great
so
I hate feelings just when that little
girl was starting to get on my nerves oh
she brought out the good in her yeah I
mean I like the I'd like to switcher of
the character because he had that the
little girl's owner believes and the
energy and the force and all that and
then the older ones more of the the
hardened shell the one who's experienced
too much loss and pain and doesn't
believe in any of that stuff and then
finds it in the most desperate moment
and I thought that was such a beautiful
reveal for her to have the character Arc
there
um but yeah I thought that was great
obviously like it's it you'll probably
just hear saying this throughout every
episode it's gorgeous animation because
it is it's gorgeous but I like the
variety of it especially with the
claymation where you part of the joy of
claymations when you can feel the scale
of the models get a sense of like the
set like you can feel some of the
filmmaking behind it where it has this
like one-two effect of like observing
admiration and also feeling lived in
simultaneously and not too many
animations house can do that and I feel
like that's what a proper stop-motion
claymation can do stop motion claymation
I don't know what the proper term is for
it is another great like
tonal display
of white people
taking over native cultures
poisoning their lands you're not wrong
that's what they did freaking whites Oh
I thought they were pretty very pretty
color palettes
no uh uh I thought they captured the
duality of grief especially in losing a
parent really really well where there's
almost this feeling of like I can remove
the force the force being the metaphor
here like I can never be what my parent
or my you know role model or whomever
you know and uh I feel like for the
older sister that was just such a
beautiful thing to capture in that
recognizing that the best way to honor
someone's Legacy is to to live it
yourself
um and the only way that that she could
do that was by being in a position where
she was helpless and had to just accept
what yeah I also like the death choice
of converting back into energy because
we're all made of star stuff so being
converted back into Stardust and
literally becoming a star that watches
over I think is a a fantastic
some people believe that that's what
happens
there's not a lot a lot of definitive
laws of science but the laws of energy
are pretty clear and you cannot be
destroyed it can only be moved and
transformed yeah so I love that being
the afterlife thought for it and I I
think a lot of what I loved particularly
about this last piece is there is such a
great
subtle implementation of other cultures
a lot of African inspiration Kenyan
cultural references that I I saw on
there and don't try to sound smart uh
sure uh I could name countries
no I mean I just thought in general it
was it's really interesting and I'm sure
like if you were to dig a little bit
deeper like I'm sure probably even some
of like the ritual elements and things
that we saw are probably coming directly
from like very Niche like yeah like
historical family culture storytelling
medium like this is ripe for that sort
of
deeper dive into something that honors
and respects culture uh and can share
the beauty of it for as long as
humankind's been around like we've seen
our ancestors in the stars and uh yeah
there's something beautiful and Timeless
about that
um overall
this is a major upgrade from season one
of Visions I feel like they they touched
on so many really like interesting
spiritual cornerstones of like
the essence of choice of like
grief
of feeling
lost and and looking for something
different and not necessarily
considering the implications of that if
it means getting out of your current
situation I turned 30 yesterday Greg all
those Concepts really resonate with me
from a lower perspective the cave
painting sequence
um it reminded me of one of my favorite
sequences in Rebels uh where they're
explaining how tarview's
saber and all that good stuff
um and I think it's just like as a
Storyteller that's something that always
kind of gives me goosebumps is that
seeing something animated on a cave wall
literally brings us back to the very
first like like artistic storytelling
medium that we had outside of being in
front of a campfire and it's just
amazing to me that in the year 2023 we
still find ways to bring that to life
and that it still gives me goosebumps
it's nice to know that me and my uncle
neanderthals uh have something
Amen to that Michael ready for the next
one yeah we're gonna end this uh YouTube
video right here thank you guys so much
for being here join us our patreon thank
you for sponsoring these segments uh of
course I'll see you guys in the next
video thanks for being here May the
force be with you
[Music]